what are the three most important
attributes that make for a good rapid
blitz player
three attributes okay i mean i think
there's one certainly that stands above
the head and shoulders above the rest
which is certainly intuition the ability
to kind of intuitively sense a move
versus doing pure calculations and what
that means is just in a couple of
seconds you can sort of sense what the
options are you just pick one based on
intuition as opposed to having to do
calculations um that's the first one i
think second one is probably just
general time management again sort of it
comes back to intuition but sensing what
moments to use the 15 20 seconds versus
making a move instantly um
that's the second one and if there's a
third one i mean i don't know maybe it's
just confidence i can't really think of
a third one specifically it makes a huge
difference i think number one would be
probably the instincts the gut feeling
second would be the calculation
and the third would be resilience
a good tactical vision good openings and
obviously good time management because
you need to always
i mean ideally you should always be
ahead on the clock if you want to do
well in this tournament for me i would
probably put intuition as as the first
i think
if you can feel good moves you're going
to do really well just because
yeah you really don't have much time to
sort of work everything out i feel like
the ability to
keep your nerves
would be
a close second for me
finally
maybe just
the experience factor i would say like
in general if you have more games under
your belt especially rapid and blitz
you'll you'll know you'll sort of know
what works well if i knew maybe i would
would be a better rapper and blitz
player myself i've really brought my
classical chess up to be the absolute
being the world elite and one of the
best players in the world and rapid and
blitz i'm good but it's been lagging
behind so i've been trying to get better
and hopefully this term will be an
opportunity to uh to improve further um
in general i think it's it's very good
instincts very quick tactical vision uh
for example if you see a tactic in two
seconds and i see it in three in
classical this just doesn't matter at
all but in blitz it's a huge advantage
so just having a very quick board vision
and uh and having extremely good
intuition and i think also having a more
narrow opening repertoire on knowing it
deeper helps a lot more uh making sure
that you can remember your stuff is is
very important because you can't think
oh uh i checked this a year ago what was
the move and spent four minutes thinking
about it it doesn't work and wrapped in
blood it's the way it does in classical
of course
to play
fast
not mistakes
last one is big luck
and
just to not miss
big blunders
calculations and instincts like this
ability to
to play fast to to have a good flow
especially in blitz
the ability to you know
muddy waters to
complicate the game to play one more
move which in classical will not matter
so much but you know what happened on
blitz it's
this opportunity like to be so resilient
that your opponent can
let you sleep slip away because
with one and uh another you know tough
move of defense
at the end it can be frustrating uh
especially if you as your parents so
that's also quite important and of
course keeping composure like um you
know because every especially in blitz
you get down to your last few seconds
almost every game so
there you really need like to be focused
on the game and
nothing else to keep your nubs
um yeah you have to be very sharp at all
the time so it's
it's
sometimes you are in a
very good shape but
physically but your mind just doesn't
work that day so it's it's you have to
be a little bit lucky so everything be
together
so but yeah it's a very interesting
format and not too many people are very
good at this format so it's an
interesting way to follow chess
well i think that chess strength
generally translate across all formats
so you won't see a robin blitz player
who's bad at classical chess or vice
versa you can't really search for
perfection and rapture with time
controls especially in blitz you have to
rely more on your feeling and
throw caution to wins to the winds a bit
more if you try to you know control
everything and make sure everything's
perfect then you run the risk uh and the
likelihood that you'll run into severe
time trouble and even if you've played a
perfect game and you're totally winning
just one blunder is enough to to ruin a
flawless game and to lose game
i think you know it's like
i think it started covering yeah who
said like there are like
three you know
three most important things which which
is just player
should have to be successful it's luck
luck and luck
[Music]